clogged arteries the way the world moves
is contributing to rapid climate change
how bad is it the united nations says
nearly 25 percent of emissions comes
from cars buses and trucks plus oil
factor u.s oil growth already showing
signs of peaking and with geopolitical
risks uncertain oil volatility may be
too much to stomach it all has us
thinking of less oil reliance and more
self-reliance and if necessity is the
mother of invention electric vehicles
are the answer to many of the world's
woes i think it's basically financially
insane to buy anything except
an electric car that is upgradable to
autonomy regardless of what you think of
tesla's ceo elon musk he's been on to
something for more than a decade and as
other car makers scramble to catch up
and outdo electric vehicles are one of
the most competitive and innovative
markets to be in
welcome to evs on the brink of change
i'm alex steele over the next hour we
will explore the world of electric
vehicles our evs ripe for the mass
adoption both promised and pursued is
the innovation and investment really
there and how do you get behind the
wheel we'll look at subsidies
infrastructure and global governments
first up it's important to keep in mind
evs are not necessarily new
as early as the 19th century many cars
on the road were already electric and
appearing in newspaper ads like this one
in pittsburgh but in 1908 henry ford
introduces the gas-powered model t and
until 1927 ford would perfect the
assembly line and build some 15 million
model t cars
it won't be until the mid-60s when we
start seeing electric cars come back
mostly concept models like the henny
kilowatt in the late 90s the world gets
its glimpse of hybrids among them the
toyota prius which rolls into america
dealerships in 2000
three years later tesla forms and in
2008 the company debuts the roadster
sports car it's followed by the model s
model x model 3 and more at the same
time asia proves to be a dominant player
the nissan leaf becomes the world's
best-selling eevee in 2010 and china
becomes the world's biggest ev market
ever its billionaire investors include
jack ma and warren buffett
it all brings us to today bloomberg new
energy finance one of the most
prospective sources on the subject says
china will top three million ev sales in
four years the u.s one million more than
230 ev models are estimated to be on the
road by 2021 so what exactly is an ev
how does it work and what's in it here's
your primer
electric vehicles a car that runs on
batteries
they work in lots of different ways
here's one of them take a tesla a 300
mile battery pack is made up of 7 000
lithium ion batteries
inside the batteries tiny ions of
lithium move from an object called the
cathode to the anode the battery is made
up of nickel cobalt lithium and aluminum
this generates a flow of electrons or
electricity
these batteries pack a serious punch
they have a large charge and discharge
rate so they produce a lot of energy and
you can reuse them a lot
to prevent the batteries from
overheating an ev uses a cool liquid
that flows between the batteries
then an inverter takes this power and
changes it to an alternating current
think of it as a voltage that changes
from there it produces a rotating
magnetic field in the motor and voila
you have power
the drivetrain distributes that power to
the wheels so you can drive your car
any electricity that isn't used like if
you slam on your brakes is sent back to
the battery pack the 36 000 chevy bolt
goes 238 miles on a charge and the top
tier tesla model s can go 315 miles
after that you gotta charge it about 30
minutes at a station and almost a full
day if you plug it into your home
the cool part is the battery sits low
and flat on the bottom of the car think
of it like a skateboard
this lower center of gravity helps
balance your driving
so does it all work
well the us average cost of gasoline is
two dollars and fifty five cents a
gallon it's 121 for an electric e gallon
you save 50 percent
now prices do vary and the more miles
you go the more expensive the car can be
and prices can range anywhere from
thirty thousand to a hundred and eighty
thousand
but the hype is hot the personalities
are big
cars are sleek
is it worth it
that we've seen how evs work who's
actually driving them mary nichols chair
of the california's air resources board
paints the picture
the biggest problem we have with
electric vehicles is nothing about the
cars or even about the charging the
biggest problem is that people don't
know that they're out there you have to
hit critical mass so people actually see
enough of them
governments from u.s to norway to
germany to china have spent billions in
subsidies to convince drivers to buy evs
with all the you know goodies that the
government is giving them and some of
the states now sort of
providing some significant incentives
for them as well the consumers are still
not buying them where they are buying
them is china the biggest market in the
world sales of ev cars buses and
commercial evs soared to 1.3 million by
2018 a huge increase in just a few years
wan gong is considered china's father of
electric cars
the sale of new energy cars has
increased nearly 60
which is very fast growth if there was a
signal it tells us that we need new
energy cars
the worries about evs are the same that
people battle in the 70s reliability and
cost if you buy a 30 000 electric
vehicle it can take you five to six
years to get paid back for that
investment cheaper better batteries and
more charging stations can help with
that
and in the meantime car makers are
trapped they have to spend billions of
dollars to develop evs which aren't
profitable yet and are forced into
partnerships with rivals to try to
accelerate that profitability whether
they like it or not the business part of
you wouldn't do these things
but that's because the leadership part
of you requires that you do it you have
to invest in things that are uncertain
that before they're ready because when
they are ready you can't catch up and
whoever finds the right formula could
win big will they be at the forefront of
another revolution or will their eevee
dreams get crushed like they did a
hundred years ago
ford has made a commitment to be carb
neutral by 2030. so we're actually
leading our industry by asserting that
the time is right for the auto industry
to take this position the company
recently made waves with an ev version
of its iconic mustang the maquis the
design challenge
was to take
what has been missing in electric
vehicles and create the passion that
follows with mustangs and marry those
together ford's goal is to have 40
percent of all its models bevs in 2020.
we think that by kind of middle of the
next decade it'll be 50 percent of
vehicles sold will be electrified to
some degree we see a big market for of
course hybrid vehicles and that will be
our
dominant technology into the future
still toyota hopes to sell 5.5 million
evs globally by 2030. what is the next
big thing for forexlogging this is it
it's i think the
electric car which is really the best
choice for many of our customers
volkswagen just increased its budget for
evs by 36 percent to 60 billion euros
for the next five years with the goal of
producing 80 models by 2025. about 15 to
16 percent of our sales will be coming
from evs there is going to be a
revolution there is going to be this new
wave coming and when you have that you
want to position yourselves at the front
of the line and it's trying to take on
the low end of the market with a car
priced under 33 000
is going to introduce 20 models in five
years he's here trenton electrification
he's here trending in connectivity so
what's coming next a lot a lot and fast
evs have transformed a lot since the
model t so where does it go from here
i think it's it's really too early to
pick you know potential winners and
losers in this and so it really is a
mess for the automakers right now dave
sargen is vice president of global
automotive at jd power and spends his
time researching global autos those who
are first to market often aren't the
ones who are successful in the long term
i mean look at tesla it's had a lot of
wins recently its model 3 was the
best-selling ev in the u.s last year
leaving its other models and the
competition in the dust the problem lies
in profitability it seems like the more
cars tesla sells the more money it
actually loses revenue per unit now fell
below 54 000 in the third quarter really
putting pressure on other car companies
we'll have very strong products coming
up and you know the penetration is
growing as well it takes a period of
time and people have different
assumptions
on how
quickly that's going to grow but we do
think this is a market that grows and we
will take our rightful share of that if
you ask me who's the biggest competitor
to tesla we don't think it is toyota or
general motors right now we think it is
large tech firms that are worth a
trillion dollars or worth more than all
of my auto companies combined these are
the types of companies that have the
ability to track talent and capital and
frankly to lose money if necessary to
take on someone like tesla
sounds perfect right people want the
cars car companies make them done not so
much here's the problem car makers are
going to spend at least 141 billion
dollars in electrification and right now
most of the cars really can't turn a
profit u.s consulting firm mckinsey
estimates that an ev cost 12 000 more to
produce than regular cars so it's a
vicious catch-22 to make money car
makers need more people to buy them to
buy more evs people need more choices
more choices means producing more cars
at a loss companies also need input
costs like batteries to come down
analysts estimate this could take more
than five years in the meantime
companies are forced into partnerships
with rivals to try to accelerate
profitability whether they like it or
not
psa owner peugeot wants to have 80 of
all its models be electric by 2023 and
wants to join forces with thea to tackle
this pricey shift this transformation
for the industry is going to be a
challenge for many oems it's going to be
a kind of darwinian period for for the
industry but hold on this is going to be
bumpy for the next few years i think
that the notion of any one company going
alone into this new future is something
that
you're probably not going to see a lot
of ford and volkswagen recently joined
forces to develop electric and
self-driving cars the business part of
you wouldn't do these things
but that's because the leadership part
of you requires that you do it ford will
build battery cars on vw's platform and
bw will invest 2.6 billion dollars in
ford's autonomous affiliate argo ai it
just makes sense for even for two big
companies to share some of the efforts
which will make both companies faster
and more efficient volkswagen and its
chinese jv partner are investing more
than 4.4 billion dollars in 2020 to rev
up production you also immediately have
the market to scale up and it'll allow
that group of companies to get faster to
market with affordable technology that
now may actually give them a little bit
of a competitive advantage for a few
years versus trying to do it alone they
have to make big investments
into a very uncertain future which
nobody really likes to do
and those evs that have come to market
haven't been able to knock tesla off its
throne mercedes just put off its u.s
debut by a year so to fight tepid demand
original equipment manufacturers or oems
need each other mckenzie says two of
them co-developing a dedicated ev
platform can reduce costs by fifteen
hundred to two thousand dollars per car
now so far a lot of these partnerships
have been with battery companies so car
companies like volkswagen bmw and volvo
and tesla are signing multi-billion
dollar battery deals as they scramble to
secure capacity gm is the latest teaming
up with south korea's lg chem to build
an ev battery plant in ohio this battery
plant is a very important part to
providing the volume for the electric
vehicles will be producing in the united
states so it will be very significant we
are bringing the best battery technology
to the joint venture to create the
future together to share the vision
that mary better laid out
all future electric car companies hope
to reduce material costs and find
synergies to free up more cash to invest
in evs some auto companies really have a
high level of urgency and have kind of
you know accepted that they need to go
all in on this but they're going to
require some planning and some support
from
regulatory bodies governments it's not
going to be easy unfortunately volvo and
geely are merging their engine
operations into a standalone company
volvo plans to roll out a new ev model
every year until 2025 to shrink its
carbon footprint and spending almost 50
billion dollars to do it
and it's the established car companies
that need the help
i think the biggest losers would be
companies that have to defend a
declining business model that is at the
margin uh obsolete and or doesn't have
the backing from the state or a national
policy to be able to absorb losses from
flipping the business model that might
sound like the average auto company and
it is and that's why experts think it's
big tech companies that will come out as
big winners you're in the business of
monetizing the utility of the platform
of the mobility device that's
increasingly going to be an electronic
device not a mechanically engineered
powered by an internal combustion engine
it's a electronic device powered by a
battery at the consumer electronics show
in vegas this year amazon intel qualcomm
and blackberry all made their pitch to
car companies enticing them with data
crunching services like better chips and
sensors for driverless cars we believe
the real commercial opportunity will be
to add autonomy to every car as a
convenient feature with the driver
behind the wheel tech can also help with
mapping and souped up navigation systems
intel says the market for such data will
be worth as much as three and a half
billion a year by 2030. it's a computer
on wheels it's a device that can be
monetized beyond its sale as a mobility
device and as a digital device last year
the world bought more than 2 million evs
in 2025 they'll buy 10 million and by
2040 56 million as they continue to gain
market share but to do it the cars need
to get cheaper so these bars show what
percentage of the car's price comes from
its battery and right now that's a 35
now this white line here shows the cost
of a regular internal combustion engine
and shows that evs are going to cost
more until 2024 then there's parody evs
get a lot cheaper and the cost of
batteries come down now keep in mind a
lot goes into this if you had a home
charger it delays this price parity by
one to three years if you're in china
evs will stay more expensive for longer
because car prices are lower than in
other countries and let's take the us
you get a 2 500 to 7 500 tax credit
depending on the size of the battery
when you buy an ev and it's available
for the first 200 000 cars sold by
manufacturer and states can offer even
more help take california it's ev sales
have surged since 2017 and if it were a
country it'll be the second biggest
buyer of evs in the world
we won't make it to healthy air without
a much greater penetration of electric
vehicles so we had to be out there
beating the drums and then we had to put
our money where our mouth was by coming
up with incentives mary nichols is the
chairwoman of california air resources
board and is a big driver of the state's
clean air rules it's not just the
monetary incentive it's the fact that
you can get a sticker to go in the
carpool lane even if you're only a solo
driver that is actually turned out to be
the biggest incentive that is the thing
that has drawn more middle class
commuters into making that choice to go
electric now senate minority leader
chuck schumer is floating a 454 billion
dollar plan where customers will be
given a substantial cash voucher to
trade in older gasoline cars for evs or
other hybrid options
when the ev tax credit was
originated
it was
literally the authors went to the senate
floor and said this is a bill to help us
get off of foreign oil we want to help
spur the production of electric vehicles
tom pyle is president of the american
energy alliance and is ardently
anti-subsidies and a huge proponent of a
free market system one of the authors
former senator hatch said we
specifically are limiting this to 200
000 vehicles per company because we
don't want to be one of those things
where everyone just depends on the
subsidy we want to spur the technology
and then let the industry go from there
many credits can wind up in the hands of
the wrong people the u.s treasury
department watchdog tigta found 70
million was given to car buyers filing
improper claims how this happens is
still unclear but the report did say the
irs didn't have a good way to prevent it
senator bill cassidy also criticized
these credits saying you have to realize
that electric car vehicles are being
bought by the well-off and being
subsidized by those who are less
well-off the bottom line is the
government shouldn't be
getting into the business of sort of
picking winners and losers
amongst industries or technologies and
even with these subsidies sales of evs
only reached 2 percent of total car
sales in the past 10 years
and then there's europe from norway to
the uk sales have jumped in the first
half of 2019 evs make up 42 of new car
sales in norway the country has a target
of zero emission cars making up all new
sales by 2025. there's this big push on
reducing co2 emissions from the european
commission and the targets they have set
for 2030 for the auto sector you can't
really meet them without a lot of evs in
the mix you can't really get there with
internal combustion engine improvements
alone europe norway although those
countries are very different in terms of
how that they're structured norway is
one of the leaders it exempts ev
purchases from a 25 value-added tax and
puts higher taxes on gasoline cars
forcing consumers into the ev option
their citizens have a much higher level
of tolerance for
taxation and sort of government getting
involved in their lives it's a very
different market there too it's a much
smaller country
they're more concentrated in you know
urban areas
germany has now overtaken norway and ev
sales just barely the country also
earmarked 54 billion euros to fight
climate change and part of that is
subsidies for evs you can get a bonus
now of as much as sixty six hundred
dollars and the auto industry covers
half the cost this should provide
support for as much as seven hundred
thousand evs you're starting to see some
of the bigger car markets so places like
germany the uk and france you're still
only a few percent of sales there but
it's rising quickly
china started subsidizing evs for the
government in public fleets back in 2009
and for regular car buyers in 2013. now
the subsidies range from five thousand
dollars to 8 500 depending on the range
of the car and were paid directly to the
manufacturers the goal is for new energy
vehicles so evs hybrids and fuel cell
cars to hit 7 million units by 2025.
the chinese government sees promoting
electric vehicles as a major strategic
priority and i think there are four
reasons one of them is cutting local air
pollution and that's a crisis in many
chinese cities today david sandola from
columbia university is an expert in
subsidies and is optimistic a second is
fighting global warming and the chinese
government has stated its commitment to
that a third is reducing their oil
imports china today is 70 dependent on
oil imports and then a fourth is
positioning their industry for the
global market in electric vehicles they
see electric vehicles as an industry of
the future china spent more than 30
billion dollars subsidizing evs and it's
paid off sales have soared since 2018.
those types of subsidies make a big
difference however this could all change
china now faces a 50 percent cut in
national subsidies and a complete phase
out by 2021 and it's had an impact sales
of evs are now down six straight months
since the subsidy cut started in july
the subsidy going away in the next 12 to
24 months or being dramatically reduced
will have a impact on
the players that's coming to market
brian goo is a former wall street banker
and is now president of x-pang an ev
company in china these players will not
have the window like what we had to
access market with the support of the
government so for them to have a product
a year from today they will be faced
with a lot of competition and very small
government support china is backed down
somewhat saying subsidies won't be cut
this july at the same time china is
funneling more money into expanding the
number of charging stations china has
eight public chargers for every one in
the u.s the darker the pink the more
charging stations an area has and the us
really only has california in the long
run it actually will be good for the
whole sector because subsidy itself is
actually benefiting the low end players
and actually
getting rid of the sexy or reducing
subsidy forces consumer to focus on the
product differentiation and quality and
value proposition which is something
that we are emphasizing as well
it's a similar story in the us once a
car company reaches 200 000 in sales the
subsidies disappear now both gm and
tesla have hit that mark and they saw
their quarterly sales fall as a result
at the end of the day it's the
manufacturers who are getting the
subsidy because even though it doesn't
go to them directly this is the only way
they're going to be able to sell these
cars so in the early stages you have to
have the subsidies when you get the
subsidies out of the system you're going
to see a desire for these car companies
to race to get a better product out on
the market that's more affordable there
is a push to extend the 7 000 credit
through 2024 and only limited after a
car company sells 600 000 vehicles which
would give companies like tesla a lot
more runway i think the united states
has got tremendous capacity to lead the
world in this area
elon musk is celebrating his first tesla
plan outside the u.s and shanghai and
tesla could now be a dominant threat to
one of the most competitive eevee
markets in the world
evs make up five percent of new car
sales in china and the government wants
to get that number to 25
fighting pollution is a priority for
president xi jinping
harm we inflict on nature will
eventually return to haunt us
this is a reality we have to face
hundreds of thousands have died in china
from respiratory infections lung cancer
and stroke all attributable to air
pollution china is the market that's
leading the commercialization of
electric vehicle technology and views
its future as an electric future and
where there's the will there's the money
there are hundreds of car companies in
china backed by some of the biggest
billionaires in the world
that all want to take on the number one
spot like x paying and its evg3 a tesla
competitor at half the price if you are
one of the top companies you have no
trouble attracting capital jack ma's
alibaba put its money with wall street
veteran brian goo who leads x-pang the
eevee hopeful raised more than 900
million dollars in 2019 and another 400
million from companies including xiaomi
most players actually are fading away
because this business actually requires
a lot of resources a lot of commitment
and i don't think most players will be
able to attract the resources and
talents and have the ability of building
an organization to meet that requirement
xpang sold over 11 000 cars so far in
2019. the china auto industry is a
relatively recent
creation
this is a it is the world's largest auto
market but it wasn't that just 15 years
ago when i moved to china in 2004 it was
one tenth the size of what it is
now it's all because of this man wang
gong who became chief scientist of the
eevee project in 2011.
coping with climate change is our common
responsibility we must recognize that we
are one of the world's largest emitters
of carbon dioxide which is why we have
been working hard in this area for more
than five years china is seeking to
create a new propulsion backbone because
it's in the domestic advantage to do so
to be the world's
base
and consumption base for electric
propulsion gives china an inside lane to
the future of mobility china is
considering a target of 60 of all
automobiles sold in the country to run
on electric motors by 2035 and the
nation is building at least 20 ev towns
for car makers in other industries
we have a responsibility to reduce
emissions we have a responsibility to
contribute to ecological civilization
a responsibility that might not see all
chinese eevee companies survive baic
blue park new energy technology china's
biggest maker of pure electric cars
forecasts a 2019 loss in its earnings
update warren buffett's back byd in
october reported an 89 percent decline
in third quarter earnings and one profit
could fall as much as 43 percent in 2019
the companies that compete here have
relatively short histories they're more
willing to embrace
a new uh technology solution because
it's a more level playing field there's
less history to have to overcome to
catch up with the incumbents and then
there's neo backed by pony ma china's
second richest person and his company
tencent they led a one billion dollar
investment round in 2017 the company now
faces losses of almost six billion
dollars over the last five years
to say that you can't ask a four or five
year old toddler to make money i think
it's quite difficult cost overruns weak
sales and a recall for about a quarter
of its cars hurt neo forcing it to cut
20 percent of its workforce if you look
at tesla it has been established for 16
years
neo has only been established for over
four years i'm sure that we don't need
over a decade to make profit the company
shells out 1.27 million u.n for each car
that sells for barely a third of that
and it also recently launched more
promotions like zero percent interest
rates for three years and guaranteed
subsidies for cars registered before
february and they're all trying to
compete with tesla the top 10 selling
evs in china are locally branded tesla's
not in that list
we intend to make continue making a
significant investment and increasing
the investment in china and tesla isn't
the only foreign company that wants in
battery
technology already is deployed at scale
in china
you can expect all the ev subsystem
components to be localized in china so
that gives china a supply chain
advantage when it comes to supplying not
only
the components for production in china
but also components for production of
evs anywhere in the world
audi plans to start selling nine new
energy vehicle models in china during
the next two years bmw will build the
ix3 crossover in china next year and is
working with a chinese partner to
electrify its mini model and daimler is
partnering to grow it's not just about
capturing the chinese market
we also want to be
doing r d there our r d team is growing
we're looking at a supply network which
is uh very interesting daimler and
chinese company gili recently
established their joint venture with 780
million dollars in capital to partner in
self-driving cars we will develop smart
together
and you will see the first fruits of
that cooperation with new generation of
products coming in 2022 so we are quite
excited about that the world owes elon
musk and his company a debt of gratitude
that it has demonstrated that there is a
market for electric vehicles
how quickly the world moves to evs
depends on money right now it can take
five to six years for you to get paid
back for buying a thirty thousand dollar
ev in the us to get that cost down
battery prices have to fall the good
news battery prices are down eighty nine
percent since twenty ten the bad news is
that might not last here's the problem
lithium producers went full speed ahead
on production betting on rising demand
from evs that demand did not materialize
as fast as the industry thought creating
too much lithium voila lower prices
about 70 of the world's lithium is in
south america and in the hands of just a
few companies and you find it in two
ways traditional mining or in brine
where you pump large amounts of water
and churn up salty mud this brine is
then left in large pools to evaporate
before processing it can take three to
five years for a new mine to be up and
running so investment needs to happen in
the next year and a half to meet demand
we estimate that out of the total demand
by 2025
around 80 will be
electric cars which is a very
significant bloomberg nef thinks the
lithium battery market could be a 116
billion dollar market in 10 years but
for that to happen prices have to fall
in 2019 an average battery pack was 156
dollars per kilowatt hour and by 2030 it
could be 63. the cheaper the battery the
cheaper the car the faster the adoption
rate
another issue with banking on
commodities like lithium cobalt and
nickel is that they might not be as
clean or as green as you think
the 20th century was the age of the
internal combustion engine the 21st
century will belong to the battery
by 2040 the majority of cars sold around
the world will be powered by batteries
they'll emit far fewer pollutants than
gas guzzlers but the elements used in
batteries have their own challenges
lithium is a water guzzler if lithium
prices stay low it may not be worth the
cost to mine the industry would likely
opt for the more environmentally riskier
method of pumping salt water underground
to extract it
and nickel is used in lithium ion
battery cathodes it boosts energy
density to let electric vehicles travel
faster and farther
but it's not clear whether miners in
indonesia can even keep a steady stream
of knuckle coming
and cobalt presents an ethics problem it
helps keep the battery cool during
charging and discharging but they're
terrible conditions for miners in congo
the world's top producer
some of the workers that reporters have
found there are as young as four years
old cleaner car might not be made more
cleanly
another big problem sometimes
lithium-ion batteries can catch on fire
lithium-ion can overheat and release an
oxygen which causes a fire now some of
these fires can be traced to
manufacturing issues in the battery
cells or installation issues or even
over charging one possible solution is
changing the fluid within the battery
typically a liquid electric moves ions
around to charge or discharge a battery
another option is solid-state batteries
which removes this liquid and uses
ceramic glass or another solid material
solid-state batteries could reduce the
flammable risks and allow for thinner
and smaller packs that can fit right
under the car seat
the energy density in our solid state
battery is over twice and what we have
today which means the space we have the
same energy let's say 100 kilowatt hour
we would take only half the space and
about half the weight and then finally
with our battery it's a lot lower cost
right now we estimate that depending on
who you would quote it could be about
half the price goldman says it could
take five to ten years for solid state
batteries to become a mass market if you
get solid-state batteries you can put
them all over the place you can even
integrate them into the structure of the
vehicle so there's a whole new set of
opportunities as we move to solid-state
batteries
the third problem is charging stations
there aren't a lot of them and those
that are there aren't fast enough
bloomberg nef says by the end of 2018
there are more than 630 000 public
charging stations around the world and
china had 460 000 of them only a quarter
of public chargers that do exist rank as
fast while the majority are in mid-range
the goal just one minute auto chiefs say
infrastructure is one of the biggest
headwinds they face
we have to kick off initiative to start
this
charging infrastructure i would love to
have more collaboration in europe and
all over the world with governments to
actually get more speed in the
infrastructure we will cover europe with
a fast charging network every 120
kilometers we're also providing access
to home charging solutions and to public
charging networks we're getting a little
bit range phobic here and there and it's
always the reason behind it is that you
know the infrastructure is not actually
progressed as fast as you thought it
should be
we work really closely with the car
companies and say how many are you going
to be deploying in the united states
where are you going to be deploying them
and then we go and make sure that we
build there so that people will buy them
and feel comfortable that the charging
infrastructure is there evgo builds fast
chargers of 50 kilowatts and partners
with companies like nissan and gm
we partner with lift we partner with
with maven general motors short-term
leasing program that provides evs to
uber and lyft what we're seeing is that
that is increasing dramatically and not
just in california but in cities like
atlanta and seattle it now has more than
1 000 chargers in 34 states and focuses
on retail we have a partnership with
albertson safeway we have a partnership
with kroger we have a partnership with
whole foods why does that matter because
the use case for fast charging
exactly matches the dwell time of going
grocery shopping you go to the grocery
store you plug in you get your chicken
your salmon your vegetables you come
back out and your car is charged
there are others tritium formed in 2001
by members of a solar car racing team
makes pumps that add more than 215 miles
of range in 10 minutes teslas promise a
75 mile charge in 5 minutes
and lucid makes lightweight batteries
for racing cars with a top speed of 174
miles per hour on one charge it has 20
percent more battery density and using
that technology in consumer cars could
be a game changer for charging
another option is going wireless for
over 10 years we've been perfecting
the wireless charging of electric
vehicles alex gruzin leads a team of mit
scientists at witrisity to connect
mobile electronic devices to the
electric grid what it basically lets you
do is move power
at a distance
efficiently from a coil that would be
say on the floor of your garage just
think of a simple pad maybe the size of
a pizza box
a to a receiver that would be designed
in and built into the bottom of the car
toyota has invested in the company and
licensed the technology and bmw used it
on their 530e i performance so our view
is we're going to make charging
completely transparent it's something
you just never
think about
what really gets me excited is thinking
about the future of mobility i think we
need to have a industrial revolution 4.0
plus for climate there is going to be a
revolution there is going to be this new
wave coming we're looking at everything
being disrupted no driver internal
combustion engine giving way to
electrification flying cars potentially
it's a matter of i think a relatively
short period of time where there won't
even be a driver we believe in five to
ten years a car will be differentiated
with how smart they are the vehicle will
be operated remotely by somebody sitting
behind a computer screen
welcome back to evs on the brink of
change i'm alex steele there are varying
predictions as to how fast ed adoption
will be bloomberg nef is the most
aggressive with well over 500 million in
sales by 2040. essentially car dealers
are going to be bankrupt mechanics are
going to be bankrupt by about 20 25.
it's not going to take that long tony
sieba is the author of clean disruption
of energy and transportation a silicon
valley entrepreneur and an instructor at
stanford university and has made a
career of studying technology
disruptions any capital investment in
the internal combustion engine value
chain today is going to be wiped out
this is going to play out over decades
this is not going to happen next year
it's not going to happen the year after
we are still at the very very early
stages of consumer adoption the future
is bright but there's still a long way
to go it's interesting that people think
that disruption and technology
innovation is a zero-sum game that you
know there's one winner and one one
loser catherine mann has worked in every
economic job from the bush
administration's council of economic
advisors to the chief economist at the
oecd to the global chief economist at
city of course it can drive economic
growth because there it is a new
technology so it's augmenting it's
expanding the sector it's expanding the
u of what an automobile is it's not
replacing um all of the gas powered
vehicles oil demand is going to drop
by about 30 to 40 percent by 2030 prices
are going to drop
to about 25 dollars as soon as 2021 deep
water oil cannot compete
and also the pipelines and the
refineries that serve those assets are
also going to be stranded for purely
economic basis you can call it
disrupting that sounds bad but in fact
it's enhanced technology it's innovation
it is responding to a need there's
pretty profound impact if we do see the
degree of electrification out to sort of
2040 oil demand in passenger cars and
oil demand in trucks that peaks this
side of 2030 that has pretty profound
implications for the energy sector it
doesn't mean that it immediately drops
to zero
today it's really hard to talk about evs
without talking about their sibling avs
autonomous vehicles in theory your car
would have autonomous software that
could be turned on updated and used with
a flick of a switch avs are not
exclusive to evs but when car makers
talk of the future these two go hand in
hand
i think it's
basically financially insane to buy
anything except
an electric car that is that is
upgradable to autonomy
there are five levels let's call the
computer jane level one you and jane
steer and accelerate together level two
jane steers and accelerates and
decelerates but you still have to stay
awake level three jane takes on the
added responsibility of monitoring your
driving environment you can check out
but be ready to control the car just in
case level four high automation jane now
drives no backup driver needed and level
five full autonomy jane does everything
you take a nap maybe you're not even in
the car it could eliminate 94 of crashes
caused by human error
city says level four on personal cars
could be deployed by the mid-2020s you
see these various consortia forming
around the world to try and jointly
develop these and defray some of the
costs going into it so some of it is
around a story that automakers want to
tell about them being innovative and
them not being left behind in the move
to a more autonomous shared connected
future tesla is by far the most
ambitious logging about 3 billion miles
on autopilot but it's expensive
companies have already spent 14 billion
on external investments over the past
nine years with most automakers
targeting commercial launches around
2022. the fact that you have both a
technology story you have a human
behavior story and you have a regulatory
story means this probably still does
take some time before it's really moving
the needle on global auto markets the
bad phantom braking not stopping for a
hazard the good evasive steering
emergency braking and driver alerts
there's also kind of this broader risk
to society that if you do really enable
level four highly autonomous vehicles do
people just drive around a whole lot
more you're probably going to see more
regulations come down to ensure that we
don't create this urban congestion
nightmare
toyota has spent most on av technologies
about three billion dollars on things
from sensors mapping mobility developers
and services now bmw daimler and
volkswagen bought here technologies in
2015 for three billion dollars the
biggest av deal ever and general motors
is also among the top five after buying
crews in 2016. for 581 million the av
company now has a 19 billion dollar
valuation volkswagen has a 2.6 billion
dollar investment in ford's autonomous
company argo ai which it bought for 1
billion in 2017 and is investing more
than four times that much through 2023
we have to expand our sense of how is
wide sharing going to affect the overall
transportation marketplace where the
world of evs and avs intersect is in
ride sharing or the catch-all phrase
mobility this can mean you using an uber
to get to work to a driverless car
delivering your lunch in order to make
the large shift to get to like two
percent ed adoption in the u.s to 10 20
it's going to be the regulatory purview
of a dense community like a city
going after logistics taxis shared
mobility fleets
city thinks the us ride-hailing market
is already 150 billion dollars and taxi
avs could increase that number by
hundreds of millions bloomberg nef
expects shared mobility services to rise
to 19 percent of total kilometers
traveled by passenger cars by 2040.
there is a real crossover between
electrification and shared mobility so
just as an example you're already seeing
uh dd in china the chinese equivalent of
uber already has a million electric
vehicles on its ride-hailing platform
there's about four million evs on the
road in china so a quarter of all evs
are using this shared mobility platform
you'll see essentially robot taxis going
around and just like you hail an uber or
lyft today or a dd are you going to have
a robot taxi neuro a self-driving
california startup backed in part by
softbank's vision fund wants to create
lightweight cars that will deliver
groceries and meals to your home it will
also deliver food from kroger and
domino's in houston next year citi says
that any ev that doesn't have an av
platform will fall behind and any av
robo-taxi that doesn't run on an ev will
suffer an eventual cost disadvantage and
lack of consumer enthusiasm just no one
can seem to agree on when this is all
happening the combination of economics
pressure from cities and also sort of
corporate image concerns mean most
shared mobility applications are going
to go electric
it's just a question of the exact timing
but i think that comes pretty quickly
the next step to mobility after evs and
dvs is flying cars we like to say that
this is closer than you think we're
aiming to actually launch our aerial
ride sharing network in 2023. uber and
hyundai teamed up at ces to develop a
flying taxi we have a network of now
eight partners hyundai is our eighth
partner that is joining in working on
this together the taxi would be able to
take off and land vertically accommodate
four passengers and cruise up to 200
miles per hour and be fully electric
with a range of 60 miles we've
endeavored to do is really focus on this
being a partnership driven approach the
vehicle companies are the ones who are
really going to be investing to bring
these vehicles to market and what we're
able to do is leverage the core
technology that we have in a way that
allows us to build the connectivity
behind the scenes and then bring those
vehicles into the platform boeing airbus
daimler toyota and porsche are all
investing in the sector and city things
sales of air taxis could reach 5 billion
a year by the end of next decade
so what will the next decade hold
experts agree there will always be a
need for cars and trucks but for the
average person the sedan will disappear
so whether it's a battery powered ev a
fuel cell hydrogen car robo taxi or
beyond there is no doubt the vehicle
that transports us and how it transports
us is on the brink of change i'm alex
steele and thanks for joining me this
hour as we looked at electric vehicles
from all the angles as for when your
primary mode of transportation will come
on electrical currents over gas we'll
have to see where governments
infrastructure incentives and innovation
drive us